-It's been almost two weeks
since the horrific shootings
in Parkland, Florida,
and the Never Again Movement
started by students
at Stoneman Douglas High School
continues to intensify,
putting more and more pressure
on Republicans and the NRA.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-President Trump's approval
ratings have fallen back down
to historically low levels
amid an avalanche of scandal
and chaos in his administration.
And yet, on Friday,
Trump went to the Conservative
Political Action Conference
and made this outlandish claim
about all the promises he's made
that he supposedly kept.
-Remember this, we've gotten --
you know,
somebody got on television
recently and they said,
"Actually this is the first time
I can remember,
Trump made campaign promises.
He may be the only person
that actually fulfilled
more promises than he made."
I think that's true.
-Oh, my God,
what is he talking about?
[ Laughter ]
Trump is so garbled,
his speeches are becoming
logical paradoxes.
[ As Trump ] "I fulfill promises
I haven't even made.
I married a woman I haven't met.
And I made a rock so heavy,
I can't lift it."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Trump claims
he heard someone on television
make that claim,
and he's just repeating it.
And I think he must have
gotten it from this guy
a few weeks ago.
-I was there four months.
You know this, Paul.
And they were saying,
"He didn't fulfill a promise."
But now we fulfilled far more
promises than we promised.
[ Laughter ]
-Does Trump think that the Trump
on TV is a different guy?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
"He's back. He's on TV again.
Ohh. I like the cut of his jib.
I'm going to copy his haircut."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Of course,
the immediate crisis
facing Trump and the rest
of the government right now
is our country's epidemic
of gun violence.
The national conversation
over gun safety
has only intensified in the days
since the Parkland shooting.
And people are demanding action.
And in response
to those demands,
Trump has spent the last week
or so rambling nonsensically
about his truly deranged idea
to arm teachers.
And today he took that rambling
one step further,
insisting that he personally
would have run into the school
to confront the shooter
whether he was armed or not.
-You know, I really believe --
you don't know
until you're tested,
but I think, I really believe
I'd run in there even if
I didn't have a weapon.
-Nothing about that is
believable.
[ Laughter ]
Forget running into a school
to confront a shooter.
I don't believe you'd
run anywhere, period.
You can't even be bothered to
walk down a flight of stairs.
[ Laughter ]
Then, again, I said before
that I didn't think he'd run,
and, man, did I get burned.
[ Laughter ]
There's really nothing worse
than a fake tough guy.
Trump lives in a fantasy world
where he's some sort
of action movie star
who'd rush into danger
and save the day.
I'm sorry, but you're
not exactly Liam Neeson.
If you've been in the movie,
"Taken,"
they would have had
to change the name.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Trump ]
"All right. So you have her?
Okay. Okay.
Thanks for the call."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
But it kept getting worse,
because Trump
lashed out at the media
accurately describing his plan
to arm teachers
as a plan to arm teachers,
insisting that he would
only give guns to teachers
who knew how to use them.
-When the press covered it,
the headline was,
"Trump wants all teachers
to have guns.
Trump wants teachers
to have guns."
I don't want teachers
to have guns.
I want highly trained people
that have a natural talent,
like hitting a baseball
or hitting a golf ball
or putting.
How come some people always make
the four footer and some people
under pressure can't even
take their club back?
Right?
-Well, even when
he's laying out his plan
to prevent school shootings,
he can't hide how much
he'd rather be playing golf.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, the only people
who ask how come some people
always make the four footer
are the people
who never make the four footer.
When Trump putts,
I bet he makes Eric
lie down on the green to try
and blow his ball into the hole.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Eric ] "Father,
I'm running out of air!"
[ Normal voice ]
Of course, the only reason
we're still talking about
the issue of gun violence
is because of the students
at Stoneman Douglas High School
who have demanded action
and sparked a national movement
for gun reform.
Their passionate calls
for action have disrupted
the usual routine
that seems to unfold
after every mass shooting.
And for that, they've been
subjected to deranged attacks
on everything from
their maturity
to their credibility
to their tone.
Like Stoneman Douglas student
Sarah Chadwick,
who was scolded by conservatives
when she tweeted,
"We should change the names
of AR-15s to 'Marco Rubio'
because they are so easy
to buy."
[ Audience "ohhs" and cheers ]
Daaaamn.
Damn.
That is a white-hot burn.
[ Laughter ]
There's only one thing to do
when you get burned that hard,
Marco.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, drink up!
After that tweet,
Fox News host Laura Ingraham
quoted Chadwick's line
on Twitter and added,
"How teens speak to
and about adults,"
calling her Stoneman Douglas
sophomore Sarah Chadwick.
Which prompted this response
from Chadwick --
"I'm a junior."
[ Laughter, cheers,
and applause ]
Laura Ingraham,
what is wrong with you?!
Don't go after teenagers
on social media.
You saw what happened
to Marco Rubio.
[ Laughter ]
So in short, Marco Rubio
might be easy to buy,
but Laura Ingraham
is easy to own.
[ Audience "ohhs", laughs ]
"Ohhhh."
[ Laughter ]
And then there are those who
have spent the last two weeks
lecturing students
on their maturity
and their qualifications
for talking about gun reform
and claiming their movement
is somehow being hijacked
by left-wing groups.
-The media's focused more
on a teenager's expertise
in supply-side control measures
for guns,
which, Tucker, let's be candid.
They probably have not studied
a very complicated,
layered issue.
-Their sorrow can very easily
be hijacked by left-wing groups
who have an agenda.
-But do you think it has been?
-Well, let's ask ourselves,
do we really think that --
and I say this sincerely.
Do we really think 17-year-olds
on their own are going to plan
a nationwide rally?
-You don't think 17-year-olds
can plan a rally?
[ Laughter ]
17-year-olds know
how to plan things.
When you're 17, you're too young
to do most things,
so you have to find ways
around it.
You got to get fake I.D.s,
coordinate alibis,
figure out how to make
a bong out of an apple,
an inhaler, and a straw.
[ Laughter ]
You got to bring Scope with you
so you can wash away
the smell of alcohol.
But then your parents smell
a ton of Scope,
and they knew you were drinking.
But they're also
a little impressed
you remembered to bring Scope.
[ Laughter ]
The attacks on these students
are clear evidence
that the movement is working.
The NRA and their supporters
are scared.
And now the NRA and their allies
are resorting to increasingly
ludicrous suggestions
for how to deal with
gun violence in schools.
Trump, for example, spent
the weekend repeating
his deranged idea
for giving guns to teachers
in his CPAC speech,
and then again
in the interview with Fox News.
-We would have had some
great teachers that were
gun adept, meaning, you know,
really understood weaponry
and guns.
And if they had
concealed permits,
you wouldn't have this problem
today.
-This is one of the worst things
about having Trump as president.
Every time he goes on TV
and blurts the dumbest things
in the world, the rest of us
have to debate it
like it's a real idea.
He says, "Hey,
I think we should take
incredibly stressed out people
who make $30,000 a year
and give them guns."
And then Wolf Blitzer
has to stand there and go,
"[Bleep]
Well, let's ask the panel.
[ Laughter and applause ]
He said it.
So now I got to ask you all.
You have to give me answers
like it's a real thing."
And there's no evidence that
anywhere close to 10% to 20%
of teachers have firearms
training, as Trump claims.
Nor is there any evidence
it would actually prevent
school shootings.
Second, there's the question
of how teachers, themselves,
feel about this idea.
And in the days
since Trump floated it,
the response from teachers,
including those from
Stoneman Douglas,
have been a resounding
"No thanks."
-You heard the President today.
He in effect wants people like
you to be on the front lines,
to be armed.
If you have the aptitude for it,
"aptitude," as he described it.
Is that a good idea?
-No. I have no desire to
own a gun, carry a gun,
shoot a gun, touch a gun.
And the President said that
those of us who would be willing
to be armed would get
some kind of a bonus.
I'm not even given adequate
money to buy supplies
for my classroom.
But now if I choose to carry
a gun,
a gun will be provided for me,
and I will be given a bonus?
-Now, I know we didn't
get to them in the clip.
But just in case you're curious,
the guy on the right's pro-gun.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I know.
I know you're all watching
the clip.
You're like, "Yeah.
What's the guy in the super
clean cowboy hat think?"
[ Laughter ]
Very pro-gun. [ Chuckles ]
But seriously,
the teacher's right.
Teachers need supplies,
not guns.
The only guns that should be
in schools are glue guns.
And they should be used
the way all students use them,
to glue the shop teacher's butt
to his chair.
[ Laughter ]
And when they're not calling
for more guns in schools,
gun supporters are complaining
that it's actually video games
and movies that are causing
violence,
as Trump did last week.
-I'm hearing more and more
people say the level of violence
on video games is really shaping
young people's thoughts.
And then you go the further
step, and that's the movies.
You see these movies,
they're so violent.
And yet, a kid is able to see
the movie if sex isn't involved.
But killing is involved,
and maybe they have to put
a rating system for that.
-Does Trump not know that movies
already have a rating system?
I love how he's always
trying to suggest things
that already exist.
[ As Trump ] "Movies should have
a rating system,
and on top of that,
you should have to buy a ticket.
I think we can all agree.
And they should have
a concession stand
where they sell some sort of
snack made from popped corn.
[ Laughter ]
You could call it corn pop."
[ Normal voice ] But you
know what -- Trump is right.
People are way too influenced
by movies.
Just take this guy
as an example.
-In fact, I have a license
to carry in New York.
Can you believe that?
Nobody knows that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What was the famous movie,
remember?
[ Crowd shouting suggestions ]
No. Remember?
Where he went around
and he sort of --
after his wife was hurt so badly
and killed?
What?
Charles Bronson, right?
The late, great Charles Bronson.
Name of the movie? Come on.
[ Crowd shouting suggestions ]
"Death Wish." Remember that?
"Oh, we're going to
cut you up, sir.
We're going to cut you up.
Oh, oh, oh."
Bing. One of the great movies.
But could you imagine
with Trump, somebody says,
"Oh, all these big monsters
aren't around.
It's easy pickings, and then --"
P-ching!
[ Laughter ]
-And you think 17-year-olds
are too immature
to discuss gun control?
He's literally making
gun sound effects.
And the wrong ones --
[ As Trump ] Bink, boink,
woop, woop, woop, woop, woop!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Huh?
[ Normal voice ] Commentators
on the right have spent the days
since the Parkland shooting
insisting that teenagers
are somehow too immature
to comment on the issue
like gun reform,
when in reality,
the only people who sound like
children are the ones
using phrases like "good guys"
and "bad guys"
and pretending that all you need
to do to stop a school shooting
is have someone there
to run in and go --
-Bink.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]